one of the things that these chapters
that we
looked at before leading up to is this
uh
this sort of broad movement in
protestant christianity in the united
states having to do with
what we could call moral reform and
you've had some of this if you took an
american history class in high school
you know they talked about the reforming
era but we're going to go a little bit
deeper into it
for this in part because we're looking
at
a whole culture that gets built up
around this
your book doesn't use this term but
maybe you
uh come across this term before
i'm not talking about the 1980s heavy
metal band
wasp uh a lot of speculation about what
those letters stood for in this case
we're talking about sociological
category
and white
anglo-saxon
protestant have you
heard wasp in terms of this concept
before
somebody's waspy nowadays we kind of
associate that
with with a bit narrower classification
but if you think about who the main
the main colonists were before we had a
lot of waves of
immigration and even after that
the american identity was kind of tied
up with
with this this notion of white
anglo-saxon protestant
and we're going to see a lot of other
streams flowing into that
but what we're talking about in these
chapters is largely this
particularly the protestant part
and what shape did protestantism take
so we've talked about the second great
awakening
and we've talked about uh revivals
and revivals are going to play in the
major role
revivals and what we call evangelical
results
your book talks about this contrast at
the beginning of the chapter
and what's the contrast between
what they call an organic society is
this a term that you guys are
familiar with an organic society where
everybody sort of knows their place
things are sort of set out
the rules may not actually be written
down but everyone knows more or less
what the rules are
does this sound familiar there's some
settings like this
in your own lives so they talked about
before the revolution the family the
church the town or parish were the
primary units of social organization
it was through some combination of their
work children were educated criminals
punished
the poor disabled cared for so they talk
about this as having an organic
character
what happens after the evolution what do
you guys remember from
just a few chapters ago the american
revolution comes around
and we shoot a lot british
then what happens the british shoot a
lot of you know
colonists what happens in terms of
religion
that's particularly important remember
that this term
the long long disc term
disestablishmentism
i think it was called it's established
in darius
yeah there you go uh so what did that
mean what happened
right what's that something without a
government
yeah um the government is no longer
supporting
any of the the churches as being the
church like
you know the anglican church in the
south or in the puritan uh
colonies massachusetts connecticut
they were state churches for a while
which meant that they were actually
supported by it by taxes
and in some areas if you didn't belong
to that
particular group you were you couldn't
really participate in
society fully that disappears after the
american revolution takes a little while
in some places
so what we have going on is like they
talk about disestablishment of the
churches
growing mobility and pluralism in the
broader society pluralism just means
a lot of different types of people a lot
of different voices
this begins to break down this organic
society
so what what's going to
replace it they talk about
people sort of no longer being forced to
conform to what it was that the puritans
wanted or the anglicans want
instead they get to decide for
themselves so
which churches are going to grow the
churches that can actually appeal to the
most people
this is a theme that we're going to see
running throughout all these these later
chapters
um revivals play a major role in that
what do revivals do they get people
worked up
and they get them to start thinking in
terms of their own conversion and their
own spiritual state
revivals are kind of unstable though how
many of you have ever
this is not going to be about religion
how many of you ever tried to change a
bad habit
that you had yeah more
i think more than just you have done
that i think a lot of people
in the class have done that maybe you
tried to lose weight
maybe you tried to start exercising
regularly maybe you tried to stop
swearing
um what are other things quitting
smoking that's a really tough one
i've known people who quit smoking 20 30
times which means
they didn't really quit um
what does it take a revival would be
sort of like that that moment when you
get all
worked up and you feel like you're on
the right track
like remember around new year's you
start making resolutions
i'm gonna i'm gonna exercise every day
from now on
i'm getting myself a gym membership and
i'll be at the gym
uh every i'll do it every morning
because it'll be a great way to start my
day
and you get really excited about this um
certainly already seeing yourself as in
shape and
and able to do whatever it is that you
want to do you start to envision that in
your mind
now what's the reality about two weeks
later
in your experience what's up you gain
weight you're gaining weight
why would you have gain weight because
you just ate
figuring you were going to lose the
weight anyway how many times
do you think you probably went to the
gym if you made a resolution like that
a couple times you know got yourself the
card to get in so you need something
actually you need something more than
enthusiasm you need something to
consolidate that
and they talk about in this chapter
pitching all this energy to
another notion which is out of
the form and we've run into this you
know word before with the
protestant reformation reform means to
change things
sometimes it means to try to go back to
where things were before
sometimes it means to do something
completely different some of the
denominations that we're looking at were
really centered around this
think about the they point out the
quakers um and this notion of the inner
light
that's a pretty revolutionary idea um
puritans were never really like they say
utopian but john winthrop with this
notion of the city on the hill
that's a reforming kind of idea the
enlightenment we talked about liberal
religion the enlightenment is a
reforming movement and then finally john
wesley's
methodism that by itself is focused on
reform
not just for the individual but also for
the
church membership so this is a big issue
already
and so some congregations are already
doing this sort of thing some
traditions some denominators are very
interested in this
when you're trying to reform things if
you're not just trying to reform
yourself
what are you generally trying to to fix
oh put churches out of the way for a
minute because these are the ones
actually carrying out the reform
what do reformers want to fix
like for instance we have an election
coming up pretty soon midterm election
that hopefully you know you've got some
sort of position on
people are going to be yelling all sorts
of slogans some of those are about
reforms
some are going to talk about tax reform
what do they mean by that what do they
want to do
make sure to tax everybody even more
distribute it arbitrarily
that's not usually what they mean right
yeah
change the standard okay so reform has
to do with
changing institutions
changing goods changing standards for
things
changing the way that we look at things
you know you can look at your whole
process of education that you're engaged
in
as a process of reform to some degree
you should leave here
a different person than you came in if
you don't
then either mara screwed up or you
screwed up
because you know with what you're paying
you shouldn't you shouldn't be
exactly the same person that you started
out as you should be a better person
in some respects and maybe marist could
be improved
uh you know when i talk to students i
find out that
some standards are not quite so standard
across the board see people shaking
their heads so you can identify with
this
and that's that's you know a lot of
places are like that to be to be quite
honest but that doesn't make it okay
and reformers are people who say we need
to change things we need to fix things
so what are these guys doing what are
what are their motivations
your book talks about this term i love
this term
of
the benevolent empire
usually when we think of an empire we're
thinking about you know
conquest and politics and that sort of
thing
an empire means a system of ruling a
system of determining
and the benevolent empire if it's a
benevolent
one it means that it's it's wishing
everybody well it's trying to
make everybody have a better condition
make them happy
the benevolent empire is a sort of
catchphrase
for this entire network of independent
but interrelated
societies all of which are focused on
reform
that were
running through protestantism
in america this is a particularly and
you might say peculiarly american thing
they have all these enterprises going on
that are not a governmental
of other people would look to the
government to to
carry out reform instead americans like
alexis de tocqueville pointed out
americans associate with each other and
they do it from the ground from
the bottom up so to speak we call
grassroots
so your book talks about a number of
different shapes that this took
you know with with these
informal system of interlocking
directorates binding the empire together
many of which are run by laymen often
have support by evangelical businessmen
and what's the real goal of all that
that's talking about the structure of it
what we're interested in
what are these people about i mean it's
one thing to talk about reform
but
you gotta actually say what you're what
you're aiming at
or else it doesn't go anywhere this is
one of the problems by the way
with occupy wall street nobody could
actually
including them could actually figure out
what exactly they wanted
that's why it kind of fizzled out even
though it had occupied movements in
other places this was a common criticism
even if people within the movement you
actually have to stand for something and
say we want to make these
changes so what were the kinds of
changes that the people involved this
this benevolent
empire wanted to do one that the book
talks about
is fostering
true religion
and let me get another pen
what is what is this going to mean um
that's much better what's what's going
to be the true religion for these people
a islam b judaism c
give you a hint it starts with a c what
is it
these are protestants no these are
they're actually gonna
in many respects be anti-catholic um
they're and we'll talk about that when
we get to the next chapter
um christianity and and specifically
protestant christianity who protest and
present christianity and you know
more or less an evangelical type of
protestant christianity
seen as being the way to to connect with
with god
to live a godly life
so there's the book talks about all
these different societies that are
founded to try to make this happen the
american bible society
is a great example what are they about
bibles
what do you think they're doing with the
bibles they're printing them
and then once you've printed them send
them out everywhere
if your view is that it's important that
people actually have access to
to the bible be able to read it for
themselves then they actually have to
have it in their hands so you're doing a
good thing by
by sending it out there bless you
another thing that they talked about
is a missionary
so americans start sending missionaries
all over the place
um out to the frontier out to
foreign countries into the the cities
sometimes which are felt to be kind of
you know godless areas
the idea was that you would you would
send these people out during doing
mission work remember we talked about
evangelicals that's something
central to them is this notion that you
have to actually spread the gospel
so your book gives you another set of
examples of these
and some people were so optimistic they
thought that americans
would probably uh evangelize the whole
world
within a century or so didn't really
happen that way there's some other
things that intervened but you can you
can get a sense of what these people
were focused on and then they talk about
the book talks about objects
of benevolence
that's his term benevolent empire so
when you see this term benevolence
do you associate it with anything
well we have you know um benevolent
associations for for police for firemen
um what does that actually mean
it's not a term we use much benevolent
it was very common back then yeah like a
desire to do good or
a good deed or an active exactly yeah
not just doing it but wanting to that's
where the
violence meaning from the will comes
from
so this uh this spirit of of doing
good and they talk about these societies
that arise to minister to for example
sailors
why sailors because sailors usually
had a pretty lousy life and also we're
pretty good
um drinkers yes
and all sorts of other things i was
going to say they're pretty good
grounds for mission work in part because
their life is so
so secular uh so they thought these are
the people that we need to go out and do
outreach to
um prostitutes they had societies
set up just to try to rescue women from
prostitution
um reclaimed drunkards sometimes sailors
and drunkards might overlap
like you just pointed out and why did
they do this because they felt that this
was part of the
sort of gospel imperative and
what they're aiming at by by carrying
out reform is conversion of individuals
and reform of institutions
your book talks about them trying this
is the really big picture
item the eventual achievement of a
christian america
there's this you know hotly debated
discussion about is america a christian
nation
and it really depends on what you mean
by nation
do you mean that everybody in america
would be a christian
no it can't be true in that respect
right because we have other people
belonging to other religions and some
people
don't practice any religion do you mean
that it was founded on
christian principles then it starts to
get a little bit messy right
um certainly for these guys
at this time they thought that what they
were aiming at
was a christian america that would not
be identified with any particular
church but would be identified with
with broadly you know protestant
evangelical christianity
in general so it would have a lot of
room for a lot of different churches
not catholics not not
later on latter day saints
and we'll talk about why in a little
while but but a sort of broad consensus
across the board
and
your book then moves to talking about
all sorts of different reform
uh
movements that that were tied in with us
but we want to look at one in particular
the campaign against slavery
and why well because it plays an
important role in american religious
history
so let me put a few
things up here we have um
here this guy william garrison
and we have uh
this guy theodore dwight weld
and then we have um
uh harriet teacher's stuff
and there's a lot more going on with
just these individuals but i'm going to
use these as sort of emblems for
for what's happening so garrison is a
quaker
and the quakers very early on were
pretty anti-slavery um they're sort of
ahead of the curve
and why because you know remember we
talked about the equality of human
beings
slavery is a direct affront on equality
isn't it
um and they were against coercion did
slavery generally involve some some
measure of coercion
almost always so the quakers are not
going to be
for that william garrison um
he uh william lloyd garrison he's the
spokesperson for what the book calls
immediatism that
means that slavery not only needs to be
abolished it needs to be abolished
now right away everything that's based
on slavery needs to go
and why because it's a direct affront to
what god wants from human beings so
he says if the constitution sanctions
slavery then the constitution itself is
evil and has to be
discarded he called it a covenant with
death in an agreement with hell
and now notice what he's actually using
there it's using biblical language
if you if you read the gospels
and the letters you will find this
language being used so the garrisonians
really get the ball moving with these
anti-slavery societies
remember reform would take the form of
associating
and getting together and saying we're
going to change things
so you have these anti-slavery societies
that that develop
some of them kind of split apart in part
over issues of
should they be aiming at immediate
change or gradual change
notice what the other big difference in
these societies is
how active can women be in it women were
quite often in quaker life at the
forefront of this
so some of the slavery some of the
anti-slavery societies
are allowing women to have a very great
role some of them are not allowing them
to have much of a role at all
weld is associated with this
perfectionist wing of the movement
and this is coming from from wesley
and it talks about these these sort of
gyrations that are taking place
where his followers are moving from from
place to place from
institutional institution so they start
out at lane seminary
in cincinnati that's where he is and he
converts most of the student body to
abolitionist principles
and they begin to work with the black
community in cincinnati
then when lyman beecher who's an
important
evangelical is off raising funds the
trustees order weld
and his followers to end their activism
so they leave
they go to an entirely different school
oberlin which at that time is
a pretty liberal place and
they they begin you know organizing even
more there's a
they start setting about anti-slavery
societies like they said in new york
ohio and other states so
it's gathering more and more momentum
why are we looking at this
lady now harriet beecher stone she's
doing something a bit different than
these guys are kind of organizers
she is a author
of uncle tom's
cap
best-selling book did any of you read
uncle tom's cabin like in high school or
middle school
like an american history class or
literature class no
it's worth a read it's rather foreign
prose
a lot of stuff from the 19th century is
but it's worth a read as a historical
document
um it's supposed to show
the evils of slavery and tie it together
uh you know an overarching christian
message
and like like your textbook points out
stowe's heroes are the weak the
oppressed the peaceable
women children blacks and quakers
and the idea is that
slavery itself is anti-christian
anti-biblical and you can portray this
in in a narrative
sorry about that um now
this provokes a sort of counter response
on the part of the southerners
so if northerners are attacking them and
using the bible
to try to argue that slavery is wrong
what's
what's the southern response going to be
then
screw the bible probably not right
so what do they what do they do then
start looking around in the bible for
justifications of slavery
and they start your book mentions just
one of these
god's curse on noah's son's ham
and if you read like the book of genesis
you'll see you know there there's this
discussion in there about god cursing
him uh and then you know in the in the
19th
even in the 18th century they were
trying to figure out where did these
people
actually go to you know who
who's who's the founder of of witch
races
and nobody takes this stuff seriously
now except for a few people
really on the fringes but at that time
it was felt to be
sort of an origin story of racist so the
southerners would use
justifications like that
and there was slavery in biblical times
you guys know about that right there's
actually
provisions in the jewish law about
slavery
so they would they would look to those
things and the bible is being used for
um both sides
uh ultimately who's gonna who's gonna
win
well we know right the north
because there's going to be a civil war
that's going to actually split
the entire nation not only over slavery
although that was really a major part of
it
did you guys when you were in high
school
american history class did you have to
write the essay on the causes of the
civil war
on your tests do they still do that
people have different lists like
the 18 different causes of the civil war
or that sort of business would they do
that for you guys
no what did they tell you about the
civil war
bad time north beat the south
is that pretty much it i don't know
because i'm not a high school teacher
so
in any case the civil war really splits
things up doesn't it
and notice it actually um
splits up churches
the three main churches that end up
getting split up because of this
are the baptists
the methodists
and the presbyterians
and some of these splits actually occur
before the civil war takes place
some of them have to do with you know
where missions are going and how money
is being spent
the baptists never get back together
this is the origin of the southern
baptist
and the at that time northern baptists
who become
the national baptists and the american
baptists that's why there are these
different
baptist denominations the methodist
church splits into a methodist church
north and a methodist church south
after the war they eventually come back
together same thing with the
presbyterian church they split apart
because people in those churches in the
south
are saying that slavery is okay it's
justified the people in the north are
saying
it's not so abolitionism ends up
splitting these churches
the other thing that the chapter talks
about is the civil war itself it's seen
as a kind of religious
event
now it's pretty easy to claim if you win
a war
that god was on your side
abraham lincoln we talked about this a
little bit before
abraham lincoln is going to say both
sides are reading the same bible both
sides are praying to the same god
and he leaves it as sort of a great
mystery why and this is the bloodiest
event in american history
we've never taken as many casualties in
any other war as as we have
imposed on ourselves in the civil war
and lincoln is sort of reflecting on
is god on anybody's side
in this this passage that ends the
chapter